hey guys mkbhd here back with another hd
video and this is the coolest thing i've
ever seen on the internet have you ever
wondered what your online persona looks
like in just a scrambled bunch of words
have you ever wanted to see what the
rest of the internet is saying about you
and what you look like online well wait
no further because a bunch of mit
students have put together a website
it doesn't really matter just take a
look at this
basically what this website asks for is
your first and last name and it'll
automatically generate a list of you
know things that it can find online
basically all it does is look around on
the internet for things about you what
people are saying about you what you've
said about yourself and put on the
internet so it can be really cool if
you're a youtuber and just want to put
in your youtube username or your first
and last name and see what the internet
mostly thinks about you also if you're
wondering more about someone else on the
internet you can put in their name too
and find cool stuff so uh leave a
comment below what does this site say
about you one of the most common words
that i get uh from when i put marquez
brownlee in were online media and
professional so that person describes me
pretty well so go ahead and leave a
comment about what it says about you and
i'm looking forward to see uh what you
get the website link will be in the down
bar where you can go ahead and put your
first name in mkbhd signing out peace
you